aumento de la frecuencia cardíaca, sudor en la piel...
Aunque los psicópatas del estudio podían
describir las imágenes con exactitud,
no presentaban las emociones correspondientes.
No presentaban una respuesta física.
Era como si conociesen las palabras,
pero no la música de la empatía.
Queríamos analizar mejor esto
y hacer resonancias magnéticas de sus cerebros.
No resultó ser una tarea tan fácil.
Imaginen transportar a un grupo
de psicópatas por el centro de Londres
con grilletes y esposas
en hora pico,
y para hacerles la resonancia
había que quitarles todos los objetos metálicos,
incluyendo esposas y grilletes,
y, como descubrí, todo de las perforaciones del cuerpo.
Sin embargo, tiempo después, obtuvimos una respuesta provisional.
Esas personas no solo eran víctimas
de una infancia problemática.
Había algo más.
La gente como Joe tenía una deficiencia en un área del cerebro
llamada amígdala.
La amígdala es un órgano con forma de almendra
que está en la profundidad de cada hemisferio del cerebro.
Se cree que es crucial para la empatía.
Cuanto más empática es una persona,
mayor y más activa es su amígdala.
Nuestros internos
tenían una amígdala deficiente,
lo que probablemente causaba la falta de empatía
y el comportamiento inmoral.
Retrocedamos un momento.
Normalmente, adquirimos comportamientos morales
según maduramos,
igual que como aprendemos a hablar.
A los seis meses, casi todos nosotros
podemos diferenciar entre objetos animados e inanimados.
A los 12 meses,
la mayoría de niños puede imitar
acciones voluntarias de otros.
Por ejemplo, tu madre levanta las manos
para estirarse y tú la imitas.
Al principio, no sale perfecto.
Recuerdo a mi prima Sasha,
cuando tenía dos años,
hojeando un libro de cuentos,
chupándose un dedo y pasando las páginas con la otra mano,
chupándose un dedo y pasando las páginas con la otra mano.
(Risas)
Poco a poco, construimos las bases del cerebro social
de modo que para los tres o cuatro años,
casi todos los niños, no todos,
han adquirido la capacidad de entender
las intenciones de los otros,
otro prerrequisito para la empatía.
El hecho de que esta progresión del desarrollo
sea universal,
independiente de dónde vivamos
o de cuál sea nuestra cultura,
es un fuerte indicador de que las bases
del comportamiento moral son innatas.
Si lo dudan,
intenten, como yo, romper una promesa
que le hayan hecho a un niño de cuatro años.
Verán que la mente de un niño de cuatro años
no es ingenua en absoluto.
Se parece más a una navaja suiza
con módulos mentales fijos,
pulidos finamente durante el crecimiento,
y con un agudo sentido de la justicia.
Los primeros años son cruciales.
Parece haber un momento para ello,
tras el cual dominar las cuestiones morales
es más difícil,
como a los adultos aprender un idioma.
Pero no quiere decir que sea imposible.
Hace poco, un maravilloso estudio de la Universidad de Stanford
demostró que la gente que había jugado
a un juego de realidad virtual
en el que tomaban el rol de un superhéroe bueno y servicial
se vuelvían más cariñosos y serviciales
con los demás en el futuro.
No estoy sugiriendo que
le demos superpoderes a los criminales,
sino que necesitamos encontrar formas
para que Joe y gente como él
cambien sus mentes y sus comportamientos,
por su bien
y por el de los demás.
¿Puede cambiar el cerebro?
Por más de 100 años,
los neuroanatomistas y los neurocientíficos
argumentaban que después del desarrollo inicial en la infancia,
no podían crecer nuevas neuronas
en el cerebro adulto.
El cerebro solo podía cambiar
dentro de unos límites establecidos.
Ese era el dogma.
Pero en los años 90,
algunos estudios empezaron a demostrar,
siguiendo el camino de Elizabeth Gould en Princeton y de otros,
que había pruebas de neurogénesis,
del nacimiento de nuevas neuronas,
en el cerebro mamífero adulto;
primero en el bulbo olfativo,
responsable del sentido del olfato,
después en el hipocampo,
que actuá en la memoria a corto plazo,
y finalmente en la propia amígdala.
Para entender
cómo funciona este proceso,
dejé a los psicópatas e ingresé a un laboratorio de Oxford
para especializarme en aprendizaje y desarrollo.
En lugar de psicópatas, estudiaba ratones,
porque el mismo patrón de respuesta cerebral
aparece en muchas especies de animales sociales.
Si crías un ratón en una jaula común,
en una caja de zapatos, con algodón,
solo y sin muchos estímulos,
no solo no se desarrolla bien,
sino que a menudo aparecen
comportamientos raros y repetitivos.
Este animal sociable por naturaleza
perderá su capacidad de relacionarse con otros ratones,
e incluso se pondrá agresivo cuando se los pone con ellos.
Pero los ratones criados en lo que llamamos
un ambiente enriquecido,
un habitáculo grande con otros ratones,
con ruedas, escaleras y otras zonas para explorar,
presentan neurogénesis,
el nacimiento de nuevas neuronas,
y, como demostramos, llevan a cabo mejor
una serie de tareas de aprendizaje y memoria.
Pero no desarrollan la moralidad hasta el punto
de llevarle las bolsas por la calle
a los ratones ancianitos,
pero las mejores condiciones ambientales
generan un comportamiento social saludable.
Por el contrario, los ratones criados en jaulas comunes,
no muy distintas, se podría decir, a la celda de una prisión,
tienen niveles significativamente más bajos
de neuronas nuevas.
Queda claro que la amígdala de los mamíferos,
incluyendo a los primates como nosotros,
puede presentar neurogénesis.
En algunas partes del cerebro,
más del 20 % de las células son nuevas.
Estamos apenas empezando a entender
la función exacta de esas células,
pero lo que implica es que el cerebro
es capaz de cambios extraordinarios bien avanzada la vida adulta.
Sin embargo, nuestro cerebro también es
sumamente sensible al estrés que nos rodea.
Las hormonas del estrés, la glucocorticoides,
liberadas por el cerebro,
suprime el crecimiento de estas células nuevas .
Cuanto más estrés, menos desarrollo cerebral,
lo que genera, a su vez, menos adaptabilidad
y aumenta los niveles de estrés.
Esta es la interacción entre naturaleza y crianza
en tiempo real, delante de nuestros ojos.
Cuando piensas en ello,
resulta irónico que la solución actual
para la gente con amígdalas estresadas
sea ponerlas en un ambiente
que en realidad inhibe toda posibilidad de crecimiento posterior.
Por supuesto, el encarcelamiento es una parte necesaria
en el sistema de la justicia penal
para proteger a la sociedad.
Nuestro estudio no sugiere
que los criminales presenten sus resonancias
como prueba en un juicio
y se los libre porque no les funciona bien la amígdala.
Las pruebas muestran que es al revés.
Ya que nuestro cerebro puede cambiar,
necesitamos ser responsables de nuestros actos
y ellos tienen que hacerse responsables
de rehabilitarse.
Una forma en la que esa rehabilitación podría funcionar
es a través de programas de justicia restaurativa.
Aquí la víctima, si decide participar,
y el criminal se ven cara a cara
en encuentros seguros y estructurados,
al criminal se le anima
a responsabilizarse de sus actos,
y la víctima tiene un papel activo en el proceso.
En un encuentro así, el criminal puede ver,
quizá por primera vez,
a la víctima como a una persona real
con pensamientos y sentimientos
y una genuina respuesta emocional.
Esto estimula la amígdala
y puede ser una práctica de rehabilitación más efectiva
que el simple encarcelamiento.
Programas como este no funcionan para todos,
pero para muchos, puede ser una forma
de terminar con esa enorme frialdad interior.
Entonces, ¿qué podemos hacer ahora?
¿Cómo aplicamos este conocimiento?
Me gustaría dejarles
tres lecciones que aprendí.
Lo primero que aprendí
fue que debemos cambiar nuestra mentalidad.
Desde que se construyó Wormwood Scrubs hace 130 años,
la sociedad ha avanzado en casi todos los aspectos,
en la forma en que dirigimos nuestros colegios y hospitales.
Aun así, cuando hablamos de prisiones
es como si volviésemos a la época de Dickens
o a la Edad Media.
Por demasiado tiempo, creo,
nos hemos permitido creer en la idea falsa
de que la naturaleza humana no puede cambiar
y, como sociedad, lo estamos pagando carísimo.
Sabemos que el cerebro es capaz de cambios extraordinarios
y la mejor forma de conseguirlo,
incluso en adultos, es cambiar y modular
nuestro ambiente.
Lo segundo que aprendí
es que necesitamos crear una unión
entre la gente que cree que la ciencia es esencial
para generar el cambio social.
Es muy fácil para un neurocientífico
hacerle una resonancia a un preso de alta seguridad.
Pues bien, resulta que no es tan fácil,
pero lo que en verdad queremos ver
es si podemos reducir las tasas de reincidencia.
Para responder preguntas tan complejas,
necesitamos gente con diferentes formaciones:
clínicos y científicos de laboratorio,
políticos y trabajadores sociales,
filántropos y defensores de los derechos humanos.
Necesitamos que trabajen unidos.
Finalmente, creo que necesitamos
cambiar nuestras propias amígdalas,
porque esta cuestión llega al fondo
no solo de quién es Joe,
sino de quiénes somos nosotros.
Necesitamos dejar de ver a Joe
como alguien totalmente incorregible,
porque, si nosotros lo vemos así,
¿cómo va a hacer él para verse distinto?
Dentro de una década, Joe será liberado
de Wormwood Scrubs.
¿Estará entre el 70 % de internos
que terminan reincidiendo
y vuelven al sistema penitenciario?
¿No sería mejor que, mientras cumple condena,
Joe entrenara su amígdala,
lo que estimularía el crecimiento de nuevas células cerebrales y conexiones,
para que, de ese modo, pueda enfrentarse al mundo
cuando lo liberen?
Sin duda, eso nos beneficiaría a todos.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.